I just want to start and go and go and
go the longest amount of time that I can
draw before the tide comes in Worcester
anyway my name is Jim Donovan I draw in
the sand to draw on the sand
it's about between a mental game and a
physical they're both equally important
I started drawing in the sand a little
more than 20 years ago
I was walking along with beach one day
it just came to me to use it as canvas I
just put my finger in his hand and made
a giant fish like became really really
obsessed with it I left behind the world
full of surfing and the job as a chef
and I just put everything into drawing
the fan there's almost no one in the
whole realm it did was coming I've drawn
in the sand around the world Australia
Uruguay Argentina Chile Russia I mean
easily at the mission but also in places
where other device passion camp I think
all could be something like the one that
was 10 miles in circumference in the
desert on dry lake a kiss World Records
are just art I've watched as much as 30
miles in one day which means about seven
or eight hours of walking I like to
stick probably the best because I like
to come down to the beach with nothing
the tools are sitting down the beach six
to choose from and I'll do my
composition do a nice big drawing and
then I'll throw the stick away I'm done
with nothing and leave with nothing
for me that's most fulfilling choice of
how to do it
jonathan is the ultimate of in the
moment and I want to finish when the
tide is adopted to destroy the time this
is going to change every day anything I
do down there is going to be gone and
every time I'm going to have a big huge
place to try something new
[Music]